hey guys it's law here with a cosmic
Wonder at the Walt Disney Animation
studio and today we are celebrating wish
and 100 Years of Disney Animation today
we're going to learn how to draw Star do
a little dubbing session for Valentino
and talk to the filmmakers behind this
wonderful film who what are you doing
Valentino don't eat
that it didn't work when does the magic
happen I'm talking I am talking who knew
my voice would be this
H I had so much fun talking to the
filmmakers behind wish but what did I
actually think of the movie for a quick
review I thought it was really good
let's start with the music it is catchy
it is Grand in scale and it's performed
so beautifully Chris Pine and Ariana
deos and The Supporting Cast all of them
really brought it for this feature then
you think about the big tracks like this
wish this is the thanks I get I'm a star
they all get stuck in your head in a way
that Disney often does visually I found
it to be stunning the art style really
worked for me it was a combination of
this 2D handdrawn watercolor animation
mixed with more of the modern CG Disney
Animation that we're used to seeing in
recent years it almost gives the film
almost like a cell-shaded look it very
unique to this film but at the same time
it feels very very familiar to what we
know and love from Disney what's a good
movie without great characters and wish
really does deliver on that front Ariana
deos does a great job as Asha she's our
protagonist she has everything that you
want from a Disney protagonist you know
she's kind she's hopeful she's
intelligent she's also just really fun
to watch they gave her a really
wonderful personality and the same goes
for the villain in this movie magnifico
played by Chris Pine I thought he was so
charming and also equally evil which I
think really works for the dynamic of
this film there's no love story in this
this isn't a character trying to find
love this is a character trying to help
her town and on top of that all the
supporting characters do their job
fantastically even the ones that don't
speak like Star you just love when
they're on screen and what they add to
the story but a big shout out to Alan
tudk as Valentino the goat uh Allan has
been in so many projects and it's really
really wonderful to hear his voice he
gets to speak as an animal this time and
magnifico may have been my favorite
character but then star is also really
Charming I don't I don't know they're
they're all great they're all great I'm
talking I am talking who knew my voice
would be this low I will say though that
the plot is not particularly complex at
all I think from pretty early on you
have an idea of where this story is
going to go how the characters will
resolve and that's okay I think it's
good to have a manageable plot something
that's really easy to consume so that
kids and adults Al light can follow
along with without getting too lost in
the sauce I think the real magic does
lie within the references and homages
that it makes to all of Disney Animation
this is Disney animations Centennial
film 100 Years of animations are
referenced here and there's a over a
hundred references in the movie alone I
mean obviously asha's Sidekicks are kind
of like the Seven Dwarves and you see a
Peter Pan like character and I won't
spoil anything for you but there's a lot
to catch and I think that does add a lot
of charm to the movie I don't think it
iies on Nostalgia necessarily but I do
think it does honor Disney pretty well
with a combination of that Disney Magic
hope and those earworms from the music I
think it's a formula for a really strong
and impactful Disney movie and I hope
that audiences like it because I know I
did but again I'm a Disney fan so you'll
have to tell me what you think when the
movie comes out we were chatting a
little bit but congratulations on this
film uh it was so much fun I teared up
during it the music is beautiful um but
I want to talk about Rosas I want to
talk about kind of the city and the
production design of it because it felt
familiar to you know things kingdoms
that we've maybe seen in Disney before
um but it also had a very unique feel to
it what was what was important in
building out that world when it comes to
you know the World building of this
movie it came from story you know so we
knew that we needed a kingdom where
people from all over could come because
who wouldn't want to get their wish gr
so uh it felt right to located it in the
Mediterranean area because during
Medieval Times which is such a fairy
tale period uh a lot of cultures uh
existed in that space and it's between
continents it's between North Africa and
the south of Europe and uh and then uh
it would give us that classic Disney
flavor of those castles that you were
talking about but it would also bring a
different flavor with the architecture
that existed there was there a character
or an omage that you're most excited to
kind of introduce in this film or pay
pay homage to in honor in this film I
can start go ahead mine is I'm not going
to tell people what it is but I will say
please stay after the credits there is a
tag at the very end that is my favorite
my favorite nod to Disney and its entire
Legacy totally yeah F do you have
anything and for me this one is not
visually on screen but we were so
inspired by the journey that Walt took
to make Snow White you know the
perseverance he has to have to create
the the first an imated feature length
film while everyone giving him lots of
doubts and saying it's impossible and he
pushed through to make that dream happen
and we put all of that into asha's
character and that has been so special
to us on this film totally and um you
know it does such a good job at at
honoring all those animation years but
also combining kind of the the tech or
the way that the mediums work right so
you have that watercolor element plus
the CG element and I'm wondering um you
know I think about Moana how they had to
develop water technology to make that
work and I'm wondering was there a new
technology introduced in this film that
helped you achieve the look that it does
have oh yeah absolutely we were we were
building on a few of the shorts that we
had done in the past and that was paper
man and feast and far from the tree
and they had started to explore this
technique in different ways and so um we
were building on that we were excited of
course to honor our Legacy we knew we
had to do something that not only had
that beautiful watercolor look the
illustrative look but also handdrawn so
and using that and then the challenge
was okay those were shorts now we do a
feature 90 minutes of that so it was uh
it was incredible it was daunting but
our artist are just amazing and they're
always up for the challenge and and we
are stunned when we see it on the big
screen it is gorgeous it is like if you
stop on every frame it's it's a
beautiful illustrative illustration it's
and we're so proud of the fact that it's
not just a flat painting right there's a
sense that you can move through those
painting and be in it and that's the
reason we chose the aspect ratio of
cinemascope is the widest screen
possible to give you that immersive
experience well being here at this
particular moment in time as filmmakers
is a great privilege and and first and
foremost we wanted to tell an original
story original fairy tale with new
characters and music and songs that was
the most important but also give nods to
the past and all the work that have been
done to lead us to this point so you'll
find throughout the film references
starting with the look of the film uh
obviously it's a watercolor look that's
reminiscent of some of Walt's early
films and and yet we brought sort of a
CG element to it to give it Dimension
and and uh a very fresh look when it
came to conversations about the music in
this film about the lyrics and what it
hopes to do for the story what were
those like when you were working with
Julia uh well certainly working with
Julia is a privilege first of all um uh
she's the youngest uh person to ever
write all the songs for a Disney
animated movie uh but what's great about
that is she has a real love and respect
for all the Disney movies but she has a
contemporary bent to her song so again
it it pays homage to the Past from her
passion and love and understanding of a
Disney musical but also uh her
contemporary flare in the
sound and what can you tell me about the
outside of the the lyrical songs but
about the the scoring itself because
that also was very beautiful what can
you add to that for us well Dave meter
you know who you collaborated with on
Frozen and he collaborated with Chris
Buck on Tarson so he's been around but
he's been working mostly on the song
part of the music uh in this movie we
had the joy and the pro pril of having
him score the whole movie and uh I think
he just knocked it out of the park you
know he brought in the emotion uh of
each character created the FES for them
and my particular favorite is what he
did with magnifico when he's turning
very bellous I think it's such a
standout piece and I think it's very
memorable I'm glad you brought up
magnifico I mean Chris Pine gave such an
incredible performance Arana deos gave
such an incredible performance and I'm
I'm curious as you know animation does
take a long time to get a movie out like
we were talking about but when it comes
to Casting and you get names like this
does that alter the way that the
characters are portrayed or like the way
that animators approach them once you
get like a you know the the big leads
cast into these roles we'll use
magnifical example we we had a general
idea of the script we had a general idea
of the character and the design uh then
we start thinking who could best portray
it uh magnifico was unique and that he
has to be uh charming and charismatic
and you have to believe that it's
someone who would actually you would
actually give your wish to for
safekeeping and yet also has to have
that ability to evolve into the
villainous side and Chris Pine had that
perfect combination and and once we uh
once we talked about Chris Pine it
became obvious that he was the only
person in our minds who we could cast
for that movie was it the same kind of
feeling for Asha as well with absolutely
and you know what it is about Asha that
when we wanted to make this movie of
Wishing on Stars we wanted the character
to be very relatable because it is
something it's a theme that we can all
relate we have a true wish in our hearts
and uh so she is in a way a little bit
of the Girl Next Door someone that we
can all see ourselves reflected in and
Ariana just had that also she's a
superstar and she can sing her heart out
and uh but she brought a lot of her own
personality to to the character as well
you know we record them while they're
still writing so then our writers were
inspired by her voice and so on so it's
uh it was magical to work with her I
want to talk about cute characters
because you know star Valentino Disney
has a knack of making characters that
are very lovable I'm wondering with
those designs because they you know they
hit so hard alen tiic does a great job
with Valentino's voice what's like the
key to making you know these Disney
characters so so lovable in these
animated films I think I think it comes
down to appeal we always talk about
appeal and even when comes to a villain
we talk about are they appealing and so
you know with star and
Valentino um you know
Star had a different origin and we went
through a lot of different iterations to
get to the Simplicity of that wonderful
just Charming little ball-shaped
character and it goes back to again
going back to our Legacy starts
basically a bouncing ball which is what
we all learn in animation 101 the very
first lesson to squash and stretch a
ball the other thing about stars is
Stars mask shape is this great nod to
Mickey Mouse so we have that and then if
you want to talk about Valentino yeah
Valentino the pet go you know talking
animal we have talked about Disney
Disney Pantheon talking animal has
always been there but how do we fit this
character into the theme of the movie so
we love that the baby ghost loves to
climb so we thought great Valentino
loves to climb he's not very good at it
but he doesn't care because it's a
journey you take that that's what's
important to him it's not the peak so
when we land on that we're like we're
all in on this little baby goat let's
put pajamas on him because Jennifer Le
CIO also love baby goats in pajamas and
she kept sending us the video and we
were like okay we hear you
we we'll put the collar we'll design a
cute pajamas and then we bring in Alan
Tuda who he did start with a younger
kind of cuter voice and then then
started to play and then came up with
this more mature very deep voice we went
oh my gosh that is so great it's so
unexpected and then alen just ran with
it from there totally I love his deep
voice well we always want you know
people to continue to have hope continue
have dreams pursue their dreams uh is
this important theme in this movie uh
and I hope that uh Disney continues to
evolve its storytelling continues to
evolve you know even the looks of the
movie because Walt did that from the
very beginning he always was looking for
how can we evolve how can we so
hopefully over the next 100 years um the
medium continues to evolve I'll have to
say as a Disney fan a longtime Disney
fan is very cool to get to see the uh
you know the formal office the working
offices of the Walt Disney and it's uh
it's very cool you'll look around here
and it's a lot of like original original
items and the way that they put the
books back are exactly the same as as
they were uh and depicted in the archive
so this is a really special moment and
take it all in and this is where the
magic was made thank you guys for
joining us on our tour today of the Walt
Disney Animation Studios and celebrating
wish and a 100 Years of Animation uh
here at Disney we'll catch you next time
on the cosmic Wonder